My name is panchik and thanks to you
I am the new michistro of the government palace.
Join me to visit my three favorite rooms,
this is the espurú room.
Look at these two beauties are presidential heads.
They used to be official vehicles of the presidents,
this one was used in summer and this one in winter.
We are now in the Golden Hall,
historic and elegant,
coated in gold leaf,
has 5m high shoulders
where I can see my beauty.
This room is always guarded by my friends.
of the honor guard
and we arrive at the Tupac room,
formerly called the Pizarro room.
I'll tell you why.
He formerly had the portrait of Francisco Pizarro,
but was later changed to Tupac Amaru.
Well,
I'll leave you to it,
it's time to feed myself,
meow